works done for the day at russian
carmaker after vas but at least there is
work russia's famous lada back in
production after a two-month shutdown
always low cost now especially no frills
so this was the first lada granter off
the production line after the pause and
it is basic and it lacks key safety
features it doesn't have the anti-lock
braking system it doesn't have airbags
it doesn't have air con
car sales in russia have crashed since
putin sent troops into ukraine down 75
percent since last july with most plants
halting production because of a lack of
spare parts
renault the majority shareholder in
avatavas quit russia in march handing
its stake back to the state
but a couple of months on from that
things aren't looking quite as bad as
they were
problems
street that's a mecca for car repairs we
meet meerab tinkering away on ajigoli
one of the soviet
like many who remember savvy at times
he's not too worried about sanctions
but there is something to the state's
repeated claims that it can beat the
western sanctions
russia's central bank and the
international monetary fund have both
improved their forecasts for how much
the economy will contract this year and
the outlook beyond that is bad but it's
not catastrophic
and in toliati auto central and home to
the worst hit sector you'd be forgiven
for thinking that people have forgotten
there's a war on
diana magnay sky news taliati